in may 2018
gina haspel's nomination as director of
the cia was in trouble
democrats in the u.s senate said they
wouldn't confirm her
president donald trump wavered in his
support
haspel herself considered withdrawing
the problem wasn't haspel's
qualifications
she'd worked for the cia since 1985
compiling an impressive record of field
service and executive experience also
many welcomed the nomination of a woman
to a post that so far have been held
only by men
the issue rather was haspel's past
involvement in a highly controversial
cia program
the enhanced interrogation or torture as
many critics said of suspected
terrorists detained after 9 11.
shortly after the terror attacks gina
haspel commanded a cia facility in
thailand where enhanced interrogations
took place including the widely
denounced practice of waterboarding
later she participated in the
destruction of videotapes of
interrogations
the interrogation program had since shut
down but it remained in the public eye
thanks to a lengthy investigation by the
senate intelligence committee which
itself had become a focus of controversy
when it emerged that the cia was spying
on senate staffers
during the may 2018 confirmation
hearings haspel reassured senators that
as cia director she would disobey any
presidential order to reintroduce
enhanced interrogation
but she resisted being drawn into
denouncing the earlier program as
immoral and she refused to accept the
senate intelligence committee's
conclusion that the interrogations had
failed to produce any useful
intelligence
for many democrats this was not good
enough
a few republicans were unhappy as well
these included the terminally ill
senator john mccain of arizona a
survivor of torture during the vietnam
war
senator mccain issued a statement from
hospital encouraging others to vote
against haspel's confirmation
in the end thanks in part to a concerted
public relations campaign by the cia
itself
enough democrats shifted their support
to haspel that she won the confirmation
vote
54-45
she was sworn in as director of the cia
on may 21 2018.
now the dispute surrounding gina
haspel's confirmation illustrated not
only the endearingly controversial
nature of the cia's interrogation
program it was also an example of a
fundamental contradiction that lies at
the very heart of the agency's existence
and which provides a central theme of
this course
the ongoing tension between democracy
and public accountability on the one
hand
and secret government power on the other
as we'll see throughout this course the
pendulum has swung back and forth
between these principles throughout the
cia's history
during the first years of the agency's
existence in the late 1940s and 1950s
congress and the u.s media pretty much
left the government's intelligence
services alone to carry on the nation's
cold war fight against communism
later in the 1960s and 70s public
support for the cold war faded and the
cia faced an environment of heightened
public scrutiny even hostility
later still in the 1980s
ronald reagan rebooted the cold war and
the cia enjoyed a revival of its
reputation and secret powers
this truce with congress and the media
was fragile however
after 9 11
revelations about intelligence failures
and covert excesses like the enhanced
interrogation program ignited a new
round of controversies
now i'm painting with broad strokes
that's because i want to give you some
sense of the larger picture of cia
history before i focus on specific
events
something else i want to make there is
that i'm not going to come down strongly
on one side of the debate or the other
case you haven't guessed from my accent
i grew up in england and although i've
been living in the united states for
several years now i still have a bit of
an outsider perspective that i think
helps make my approach to the cia fairly
objective
i should also explain that although i've
researched and written about the history
of the cia for years and interviewed
lots of former spies i don't have a
background in intelligence myself
not unless you count a grandfather who
did some mysterious work for the british
government during world war ii
when people asked what got me interested
in this subject i tell them that like a
lot of people i've always been
fascinated by spies and spying i'm just
lucky that i get to study the cia for a
living
in any case my overall aim in this
course is not to tell you what to think
but rather to provide you with the
evidence for you to decide
has the cia fulfilled its difficult
mission as the secret intelligence
service of the world's largest democracy
in this first lecture i'll concentrate
on the origins of the cia in particular
i'm going to try to answer the question
why did the united states feel that
necessary to create a secret foreign
intelligence service
after all this is a nation that's never
been entirely comfortable with
government secrecy nor for that matter
with involvement in foreign affairs in
tackling this question i'm going to
cover three main periods of u.s
government intelligence before the birth
of the cia in 1947.
first from the era of the american
revolution to the late 1930s
second during the years of world war ii
and the wartime office of strategic
services or oss the cia's most obvious
predecessor
and finally the period immediately after
the war from 1945 to 1947.
as you'll see the tension between
secrecy and democracy isn't unique to
the cia
it's as old as the united states itself
the first point to make about the
creation of the cia is that it happened
relatively late
the spy services of other major powers
date back to the early 1900s great
britain's mi6 for example and the soviet
checker a predecessor to the kgb
francis de jamburo can be traced to the
1870s
there are several good reasons for this
two vast oceans naturally defended the
united states so that it didn't need
intelligence about possible threats to
its security in the same way that the
europeans did
by and large america lacked foreign
enemies or overseas possessions that it
had to defend
finally its people didn't like the idea
of secret government power
espionage and covert operations were
dirty tricks something undertaken by the
corrupt imperial governments of the old
world not the virtuous young republic of
the united states
still for all the americans dislike of
spies and spying there were times of
national emergency when the country did
resort to secret intelligence
usually this was when the nation was at
war and its leaders felt an urgent need
to find out what the enemy was thinking
and planning for military purposes
uh this might involve sending spies into
the enemy camp to eavesdrop on
conversations
or more sophisticated means like the
interception and military signals
traffic
whatever the technology this was
espionage gathering information by
secret and as far as the enemy was
concerned illegal means
but secret intelligence work might also
go beyond espionage to include covert
action that is clandestine operations
designed to hurt enemies
this could involve sabotaging their
supplies or deceiving them about troop
movements or demoralizing them by
spreading false or doctred information
theoretically espionage and covert
operations could be carried out by
separate units but in practice they've
tended historically to be housed in the
same organization
despite americans traditionally anti-spy
perspective they've always used
espionage and covert action in moments
of crisis starting with the founding of
the nation
early in the american revolution george
washington set up a committee to
communicate secretly with sympathisers
abroad he also regularly sent spies into
british occupied territory in the
colonies
indeed one of the first martyrs of the
american cause was a spy
the british court young nathan hale on a
secret mission on long island and hung
him on a street corner in manhattan
hale's last words became a famous earthy
statement of american patriotism
i only regret that i have but one life
to lose for my country
washington also practiced what today
would be called counter intelligence
rooting out british spies within the
american camp
benjamin tolmaj
head of the culpa spiring in new york
helped to catch the notorious american
traitor benedict arnold
and the further precursor to the present
day both sides in the revolutionary war
use codes to communicate and try to
break those of each other
the americans eventual victory over the
british was due in part to a classic
deception operation
fake american dispatches fell into the
hands of british spies and british
general charles cornwallis was trapped
at yorktown
still for all the importance of
espionage and covert action during the
american revolution citizens of the
young republic never really took spying
to heart
it's telling that the secret agent most
remembered from this period wasn't the
brave young patriot nathan hale it was
the turncoat benedict arnold
after the revolution other founding
fathers besides washington most notably
thomas jefferson tried to create a
permanent secret service for the new
republic but nothing lasting resulted
this pattern of intelligence growing in
importance during time of war and fading
again after the return of peace repeated
itself throughout american history
during the civil war abraham lincoln
hired the private detective alan
pinkerton to provide security for the
union side and to gather information on
the confederacy
pinkerton was a fascinating personality
with many talents as an intelligence
chief including a flare for publicity
after the war he earned headlines by
going after the famous outlaws frank and
jesse james
however this adventure backfired when
pinkerton agents wounded the bandit's
mother and killed their young
half-brother
this incident combined with the
pinkerton's involvement in the bloody
labor battles of the late 1800s
contributed to americans dim view of the
spy profession even after the union
victory
now the world war one era did see the us
government enter further into the
intelligence business than it ever had
before
the state department created an elite
central intelligence unit called u1
a colorful character named herbert yardy
ran a code-breaking operation known as
the black chamber
and in 1924 a young detective by the
name of j edgar hoover became director
of the bureau of investigation later the
federal bureau of investigation
the government appeared to be gradually
taking over the business of national
security from private agencies like the
pinkertons
the moment didn't last however
as americans retreated into isolationism
after world war one the anti-spy
tradition came roaring back
the government closed down u1 and the
black chamber
secretary of state henry stimson summed
up the general attitude toward
intelligence work in 1929 when he
declared
gentlemen do not read each other's mail
this was the background to the approach
of world war ii
and one of the greatest intelligence
shocks in american history japan's
surprise attack on pearl harbor
now there are several theories as to why
exactly washington missed signs of the
imminent japanese attack in december
1941
but most historians agree that two
factors were crucial
one was a failure by politicians to
imagine that the japanese were capable
of such an attack
the other was a lack of specific
intelligence pointing toward the precise
timing and place of the raid
whatever its exact causes portal harbour
would have huge consequences for the
subsequent development of u.s
intelligence
first it created a strong argument for
those advocating a permanent
intelligence agency that will function
in peacetime as well as war and
therefore be able to warn the nation of
surprise attacks
of course the downside of this would be
that if there were another surprise
attack as in september 2001 the
permanent intelligence agency would get
the blame
second and more immediately pearl harbor
brought the united states into world war
ii and in doing so it dealt a huge blow
to the isolationist anti-spy habits of
mind that had previously slowed the
growth of american intelligence
we now enter the second phase of u.s
intelligence history that of the office
of strategic services or oss
if any single individual could be called
the father of the cia it's william wild
bill donovan who was bill donovan
well unlike many of his contemporaries
in the intelligence world donovan was
not upper class by birth
but he was handsome brave and well
fortunate
born in 1883 to irish immigrant parents
in buffalo new york donovan studied hard
and earned a place at columbia
university
there he won a prize for oratory starred
as quarterback on the football field and
befriended future president frank finn
roosevelt
upon graduation donovan practiced
corporate law and he served heroically
in france during world war one earning
several wounds and acquired again
later after returning to his law
practice he built up a small fortune and
launched himself on a career in politics
now it's at this point that donovan's
luck seemed to desert him
a bid for the new york governorship in
1932 fizzled out
and he drifted for several years unsure
of his next step
one way he filled his time during this
period was indulging a growing love of
foreign adventure especially the secret
adventure his friend franklin roosevelt
was now president and roosevelt sent him
on a series of semi-official covert
missions to europe and asia
in 1940 fdr dispatched donovan to london
to assess britain's chances of surviving
a nazi invasion
during his visit donovan had
extraordinary access to british
intelligence
and he began to formulate a plan for an
american secret service modeled largely
on mi6
when donovan returned to the united
states with this plan he encountered
opposition from j edgar hoover who saw
it as a threat to the fbi
the state department and military
intelligence units such as the office of
naval intelligence and the army's g2
also opposed the idea
but it didn't matter
the president shared donovan's regard
for the british and wanted to prepare
the country for the war that was surely
coming
in the summer of 1941 roosevelt
appointed donovan the coordinator of
information a sort of intelligent
supremo
with historically unprecedented powers
over the existing civilian and military
agencies
after pearl harbor the function was
renamed the office of strategic services
or oss
and the united states had its first
central intelligence agency
what to say about while bill donovan's
office of strategic services and its
wartime record
well there's been a lot of myth-making
about the oss contribution to the allied
war effort
in fact the spy service was excluded
from several major theatres of the
conflict including all of the americas
which j edgar hoover claimed for the fbi
the oss also had to deal with the
constant suspicion of the state
department and the military intelligence
agencies
and while donovan was an inspirational
leader of the men and women under his
command he was a terrible administrator
one subordinate compared his management
style to a man pouring molasses from a
barrel onto the table
the oss became involved in some
ludicrous schemes for example a plot to
drive hitler insane with lust by
showering his headquarters with
pornography
but for all its organizational chaos and
silly ideas the oss had a fine overall
war record
its special operations branch ran
guerrilla campaigns in occupied
territory that inspired local resistance
movements and distracted the enemy
these included the jedbas
teams of american and british officers
who parachuted behind german lines to
help french resistance fighters cut nazi
supply lines ahead of the normandy
landings
then there was the quiet heroism of the
staff in the washington-based research
and analysis branch
these were intellectuals and scholars
including i'm proud to say many
historians
who worked day and night to supply
military commanders with battlefield
intelligence
finally the overseas stations of the
secret intelligence branch also achieved
a number of notable espionage successes
including establishing contact with the
german officers who plotted to
assassinate hitler in 1944.
to sum up the oss world war ii
performance bill donovan had several
obvious shortcomings but he shouldn't
distract from the fact that he succeeded
almost overnight at creating a dynamic
courageous and imaginative intelligence
organization one that it's possible to
argue contributed significantly to the
eventual allied victory at the very
least that proved a considerable
nuisance to the enemy
the office of strategic services was
also important historically as the
forerunner of the cia
how so in what ways did the oss shape
the character of the cia
i'll return to each of these points in a
later lecture so i won't dwell on them
long for now but first there was the
obvious factor that many people who
served in the oss went on to serve in
the cia including no fewer than four
directors of central intelligence
second the oss had a distinctly ivy
league anglophile even aristocratic air
to it according to some oss stood not
for officer strategic services but
rather for oh so social
and this social identity carried over
into the cia at least during the
agency's early years
this would give the new intelligence
organization a strong sense of social
cohesion an esprit de corps
but it would also earn the mistrust of
those who were suspicious of elites and
foreign influences
and it didn't help that the oss and cia
were the creations of democratic
presidents many conservatives saw them
as outgrowths of liberal big government
endangering american freedoms
finally the oss prefigured the cia in
that it housed intelligence work and
covert action under one roof
in some ways this was a logical
arrangement intelligence and covert
action were both by definition secret
mission so it made sense to lump them
together
but there was also an implicit tension
between intelligence which involved
observing and describing the world and
covert action which meant trying to
change the world
this wasn't necessarily a problem so
long as the two missions were given
equal weight
but bill donovan's natural inclination
was to all covert action rather than
intelligence work
this preference would be inherited by
the cia with sometimes unfortunate
consequences
the cia wasn't born yet however
after world war ii ended in 1945 the
familiar pattern of the us government
pulling back from intelligence work
during peacetime appeared again
bill donovan tried to fight the tide he
lobbied the white house with a plan for
a permanent civilian intelligence agency
but opponents in congress and the media
attacked the proposal they complained it
would mean more big government and
compared it to the nazi secret police
the gestapo
the isolationist chicago tribune
ran the headline
new deal plans to spy on world and home
folks and super gestapo agency is under
consideration
it's possible that fdr might have
supported his friend donovan but the
president died in april 1945 and his
successor harry truman turned out to
share the concerns of donovan's critics
he actually used the term gestapo
several times himself
furthermore the missouri democrat truman
personally disliked donovan who is an
ex-wall street republican
in september 1945 the president ordered
the breakup of the oss and donovan found
himself back on wall street practicing
corporate law again
post world war ii america it seemed
would be no place for spies
so what changed between 1945 and 1947
both restart harry truman's mind
the post-war world was a confusing
threatening place especially for a
president with little experience in
foreign affairs
also truman didn't much care for the
lengthy and he felt patronizing
briefings he was getting from career
foreign service officers in the state
department
so in january 1946 truman established a
new body the central intelligence group
not agency yet
to provide him with daily foreign
intelligence digests a sort of white
house news desk
to run this body truman turned to a
trusted friend and fellow midwesterner
rear admiral sydney surs
the two men performed a mock ceremony in
the oval office the president presented
sews with a black cape and wooden dagger
and declared him director of centralized
snooping
this was a big step forward but the
central intelligence group still had no
intelligence gathering capability of its
own and no powers of covert action
truman's timing proved just right
because the international environment
really began to deteriorate again in
1946
and now you get the second and main
reason why the cia was created the start
of the cold war
the two post-war superpowers the united
states and soviet union
failed to reach an agreement on how to
deal with various countries in eastern
europe after the war the soviets wanted
them firmly within moscow's sphere of
influence to act as a buffer zone
against possible future foreign
aggressors
the americans wanted them independent
part of a new international order that
implicitly favored u.s interests
from this initial disagreement
superpower tensions escalated at an
alarming speed each move by one side
seemed to increase the others feelings
of insecurity
gradually a new pattern of conflict
emerged which the two nations used any
mean short a direct military conflict to
check the other it was a cold war rather
than a hot war
superpower tensions came to a head in
1947.
in march of that year president truman
went before congress to announce what
became known as the truman doctrine
this was a new foreign policy committing
the united states to defending smaller
nations threatened by soviet takeover
truman didn't explicitly mention the
soviet union but it's pretty clear
that's what he meant
that june secretary of state george
marshall proposed u.s assistance to
rebuild the war-shattered economies of
western europe the marshall plan was
another escalation of the cold war
then in july truman signed a national
security act
creating the central intelligence agency
and much of the modern u.s national
security apparatus
unlike the earlier central intelligence
group the cia had its own independent
powers of intelligence gathering and the
ability to perform undefined
other functions and duties related to
intelligence
these words would soon be interpreted to
mean covert operations
decades after the other great powers the
united states had its own permanent
intelligence service at last
to sum up the united states had a long
history of espionage and covert action
prior to the birth of the cia in 1947.
however americans also entertained a
strong suspicion of international
involvement and excessive government
power
it wasn't until the extraordinary
conditions of the 1940s when a hot world
war was swiftly followed by a cold one
that advocates of intelligence and
internationalism overcame the anti-spy
tradition
the cia for roughly the first two
decades of its existence would have an
unprecedented amount of operational
freedom
but even during the summer of 1947 there
were some who hesitated before creating
a peacetime intelligence agency
one republican congressman protested
that no president should have a gestapo
of his own
an isolationist newspaper went so far as
to warn about the dangers of creating a
super duper gestapo oss cloak and dagger
organization
and this fear of the government's
potential to abuse its secret powers
would return to haunt the cia throughout
its existence
right down to the present day
[Music]
you